el vaticano rompe el silencio
dos días después de que rolando álvarez
el obispo de matagalpa un municipio en
el centro de nicaragua y crítico del
presidente nicaragüense daniel ortega
fuera detenido el papá francisco
finalmente se pronunció se guarda vicino
con preocupaciones y dolores sigo de
cerca con preocupación y dolor la
situación que tiene lugar en nicaragua
que involucra a personas instituciones
o leyes primera convención en el
expresar mi convicción y mi deseo de que
a través de un diálogo abierto y sincero
se puedan encontrar las bases para una
convivencia respetuosa y pacífica
la declaración llega tras las críticas a
las máximas autoridades de la iglesia
católica de permanecer ajenas a la
situación en el país centroamericano en
donde la persecución a sus
representantes por parte del gobierno de
daniel ortega es recurrente álvarez fue
detenido por supuestas acciones
desestabilizadoras y provocadoras junto
a cinco sacerdotes una ola de arrestos
que encendió las alarmas a nivel
internacional la organización de estados
el consejo episcopal de américa latina y
el caribe y la onu condenaron los hechos
las voces de rechazo se escucharon desde
costa rica donde reside una amplia
comunidad de nicaragüenses en el exilio
a la iglesia católica por parte de la
vida
ortega ha catalogado a los obispos de
terroristas por su mediación en un
diálogo nacional que pretendía buscar
una solución a la crisis que atraviesa
el país desde 2018 año en el que explotó
el descontento social en las calles el
mandatario asegura que se trató de un
complot entre la oposición en eeuu para
destituirlo bajo la complicidad de los
sacerdotes